tell us about Airbnb how did you get
involved with with that company so eBay
and Amazon started in the mid 1990s
bunches of others started selling
products around the same time fact
match.com
started thinking about how to facilitate
dates in the mid 1990s so there are
implications of platforms like eBay and
Amazon one is that markets will be more
efficient so prices might come down your
availability of products might go up but
in addition to the efficiency
implications people had explored the
equity implications of platforms like
eBay and Amazon what they had thought
about is not only will markets become
more efficient but people have posited
that markets would also become fairer
there is a great paper that I looked at
transactions for cars that initiated
online and they had iPod the size that
by buying this online where you're not
kind of face-to-face and looking at the
person that you might get rid of a lot
of the discrimination and in fact what
they found is that an offline purchases
they saw the same types of
discrimination that they had seen before
but in online purchases that they had
seen most of this discrimination I got
away and when you look at a platform
like Airbnb they're making very
different design choices they're showing
you not only the listing where you might
stay but the person you might stay with
they're giving hosts a lot of
flexibility about about who was going to
stay with them and we ran an experiment
in which we tested we tested the tested
for discrimination on the platform and
we found that so we had followed an
audit study methodology that really
within economics have been pioneered by
Marianne Bertrand and Santo Lewin up in
now where we have looked at the names of
the guests that were going to be staying
somewhere so we took names that were
statistically most likely to be a white
person and statistically most likely to
be African American person and what we
could see is that if you have a name
that is statistically more likely to be
african-american that you're about 16%
less likely to be accepted for an Airbnb
relative to the same application with a
white sounding name
so eventually Airbnb I put together our
committee I'd spoken several times the
people at Airbnb about steps that they
could take to reduce discrimination then
in there
committee they laid out a series of
changes that they were going to make to
a platform to try to reduce the amount
of discrimination what else is going on
in Airbnb so everybody has a few issues
that they struggle with yeah the way
that I think about them is
discrimination is one set of issues
they've been thinking about taxes or an
issue that they've been thinking about
so thinking about somebody who rents out
place as an Airbnb should they be paying
taxes as income as an individual should
they be paying taxes at the hotel tax
rate so these are open policy questions
that policymakers are thinking about and
that Airbnb has high-powered incentives
to try to shape as well yeah
externalities is an enormous issue that
Airbnb struggles with thinking about an
apartment building if the person next to
you takes their place and sublet sistas
and Airbnb and you have a different
person staying there every night this
imposes an externality on the neighbors
so policymakers are trying to think
through how do you deal with this
externality in many many cases for
example if you have a cooperative or
even in a condominium you convicting can
make the rules so I certainly feel with
those who don't want their neighbors
renting their room is there as their as
a hotel room but presumably the coop
Association can just ban it without the
need of actually public regulation right
sure so for some buildings so buildings
are making regulations in a lot of these
situations cities are also getting
involved in what the regulation should
be and one feature of the digital age is
lots of people who moved into a place
weren't necessarily thinking about even
the potential of a platform like Airbnb
when they purchased a place so right so
if short-term rentals were allowed in
1995 that may have felt very different
than short-term rentals being allowed in
2015 do you think cities are
differentially affected by these new
tech net works relative to other places
so when we think about some of the first
generation of online platforms the thing
about Skype Amazon eBay yeah these
disproportionately you might have
thought would help people who are living
outside of cities somebody who could now
order something from a city that
otherwise would have been unavailable
somebody who could telecommute from a
place that previously would have been
inaccessible but in recent years what
we've actually seen is a series of
platforms that have
popped up that require network effects
so they need a certain amount of market
thickness for them to successfully
launch in an area and those platforms
exactly why you burst Arts in San
Francisco and why so many platforms
start in San Francisco and New York and
not in more rural areas and in that
world there's been a benefit that at
least thus far has disproportionately
accrued to urban areas
you